We know that the snake is utilized conceptually
and metaphorically as representation of transformation,
right because the snake is something that
can shed its skin and be reborn.
We know that a snake is something that’s
innately attractive and terrifying to human
beings and other primates so that if you come
across a snake, you’re likely to be at least
startled, if not horrified by it but also
attracted to it in a way that is underneath
your voluntary consciousness,
right, because snakes attract orienting reflexes
and they activate the systems underneath your
consciousness that actually govern the structure
of that consciousness.
We know that the snake can be well represented
as well as internal chaos so imagine this.
Imagine that it’s not unreasonable for a
self-conscious mind searching for a mode of
self-representation to remark on the parallels
between the structure of the snake and the
spine and the brain given that a snake is
essentially a spine with a brain and then
imagine as well that the most archaic aspects
of our nervous system, those that govern novelty
and orienting and anxiety responses or in
fact precisely those that were described by
McLean as nested inside the reptilian brain
and then imagine along with the Hindu Yogis
that the purpose of Kundalini Yoga is to activate
the circuitry that’s associated with that
snake so-to-speak, to produce a permanent
state of alert wakefulness that’s associated
with consciousness.
So imagine this.
Imagine an animal like, like a zebra, grazing
mindlessly in the herd with no consciousness
whatsoever.
And then imagine its relatively undeveloped
cortical structures activated suddenly by
the movement of a lion off in the perimeter.
And then imagine for that brief
moment, that that zebra’s actually conscious,
a state that requires a tremendous amount
of energy and difficult to maintain,
but because the threat and the uncertainty
manifests itself within the Zebra’s mode
of consciousness it wakes momentarily.
And then imagine that human beings are like
that zebra, always.
Because we’ve become so conscious, because
we note that the unknown is around us all
the time, even when we think we’re safe,
we’re never safe.
Imagine that the reason we’re so conscious
is because as a consequence of our discovery
of the possibility of our own mortality, all
this underlying circuitry that in other animals
is only apparent when they’re startled or
afraid or interested or curious.
In human beings it’s on all the time and
that’s what makes us conscious
and the reason for that is because we developed
enough cortical elaboration to note that we’re
always threatened by everything that’s around
us.
And then imagine that – well that’s pretty
awful isn’t it?
because it’s at the basis of all our innate
existential terror – but then imagine as
well that without that terror pushing us forward
and and our constant reference to the dangerous
aspect of the unknown, we would have never
been motivated to produce the kind of societies
that we’ve produced which are essentially
very remarkably elaborated devices that enable
us to find some protection from that unknown
and to manipulate it effectively.
And then remembering that story, we’ll return
to Genesis.
Jung says the snake was regarded by early
Gnostic Christians as a kind of deity whose
faculties were more developed and advanced
than the original Deity that actually structured
the world,
the idea there being that the world initially
was a pretty abysmal place.
Everyone wasn’t conscious.
We all existed at the level of the animal
and then the snake came along and said, “wake
up, wake up”.
And the movement from that state of unselfconsciousness
paradise to this profane state of awakening
can be regarded not so much as a descent but
as an ascent of sorts even though a painful
one.
And then you have Goethe’s commentary from
Mephistopheles, his representation of Satan
and his capacity for temptation who says:
"follow the adage of my cousin snake/ from
Dreams of Godlike knowledge you will wake
/ to fear in which your very soul shall quake."
A statement associateing the human tendency
to attribute to all revolutionary sources
of new information a kind of demonic being.
And then you have the problem of the woman.
Now we know that within the context of the
Judeo-Christian tradition women have unduly
suffered for their role in tempting humanity
in the embodied form of Adam towards higher
order self consciousness
and then you think well, let’s just take
a look at how human beings and their mating
relationships differ from those of other animals
like chimpanzees to whom we are very closely
genetically related.
And if you look at the mating strategies of
female chimpanzees you see that they really
don’t care who they sleep with, so to speak.
Any old chimpanzee will do.
Now, the less dominant male chimps tend to
be chased away by the more dominant male chimps
but if a female and less dominant chimp can
get the hell away from the watchful gaze of
the dominants already, they’re perfectly
happy to mate.
Human females are not like that.
They’re selective maters.
And there’s a tremendous body of evolutionary
psychological information that suggests that
although both genders value intelligence and
physical appearance, females value the ability
to attain dominance hierarchy status in men
far more than men admire the ability to attain
dominant status in women.
which is to say that men don’t care what
a woman has with regards to potential for
attaining status, whereas with women it’s
one of the strong determinants of mating preference.
So then let’s say look we don’t know why
the hell our cortexes expanded so rapidly
somewhere between five and three million years
ago.
Let’s offer this as a hypothesis.
The women started to get choosy and because
they were so damned complicated the whole
human species had to exaggerate its cortical
growth prior to any even use for that cortical
growth just so that the men had an even hand
in the competition, right.
So women put tremendous selection pressure
on the human being to develop tremendous,
tremendous cortical expansion.
Now, we already know that from the mythological
perspective that women are frequently cast
into the same conceptual domain - the temptress
domain - as the benevolent aspect of the unknown
and we know as well from representations of
hero mythology that it is the individual who
goes out to confront chaos whose most likely
to free from the dragon not only treasure
but a virgin say in the case of mythological
representations like say George and the Dragon.
So then we close with the notion of voluntarism
and in the Old Testament in Genesis, there’s
now there’s this notion that not only did
people become self-conscious because they
did something but they did this voluntarily
right?
They they they made this decision on their
own.
So Milton puts words into God’s mouth and
says, "So will fall/ He and his faithless
progeny: whose fault?
/ Whose but his own?
/ ingrate, he had of me/ All he could have;
I made him just and right,/ sufficient to
have stood, though free to fall.”
and then you think if you think well maybe
the notion of the heritable sin of Adam characterizing
human beings and their fallen existential
condition isn’t just the black-hearted ravings
of fundamentalist southern Baptist lunatics.
Right?
There’s something to this.
Human beings are the only creatures that seem
to live at odds with their own experience
and it’s not so unreasonable to suppose
that it’s our dawning capacity for self
consciousness that put us in that uncomfortable
position.
So why do I associate the eating of the apple
with self consciousness?
Well, it’s because that’s how the story
lays itself out.
You have the collateral evidence of the Buddhist
story of enlightenment, right?
His contact with death.
You have multiple medie, medieval representations
of Eve offering to animal, to Adam not an
apple but a skull.
You have multiple representations of the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil in the medieval
iconography as not containing apples but containing
skulls.
And you have the the statements that are within
the context of Genesis itself.
"And the eyes of both of them were opened.
And they knew that they were naked.
And they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons.
Well, there’s a lot of information packed
into those two lines, right?
What does it mean to have your eyes open?
Well half your brain is visual cortex.
it’s not unreasonable to presume that that
means that quick, a quick magnification of
consciousness.
You’re conscious during the day.
That’s when your eyes are open.
But what happens when your eyes are open?
Well, you know you’re naked.
Well what does that mean?
Well, you know you’re vulnerable, right
to social comment, to social judgment, to
dominance, hierarchy, status manoeuvering
and to all the terrible things that the unknown
world can can heap upon you.
And so then what do you do?
Well you create culture.
Right?
And that’s what this little sentence said.
"And they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons."
That’s a pretty eventful sequence all crammed
up in two little sentences.
So then what happens?
Ah I think it’s extremely interesting.
So before Adam and Eve figure out that they’re
naked, they’re cruising around the garden
having a fine time doing whatever they want.
They don’t take any thought for the future,
right?
They don’t have a pre frontal cortex.
They’re living in a, in a paradox-less environment
like an animal lives.
Well what happens after they become self conscious?
Well, prior to this Adam’s walking around
with God right?
And you think about what that means.
Does it mean something like this?
An animal isn’t in the world of good and
evil.
An animal like Nietzsche points out is beyond
good and evil, right?
Enraptured in te, entirely by the actions
of automatic instinct, governed by processes
that are completely transcendent.
The animal’s nothing but a force of nature.
There’s no opposition between the animal
and the world.
The animal is the world.
And just as in the case of the animal prior
to the eating of the apple, Adam walks around
the garden with God.
There’s no discontinuity between Him and
the, and the transcendent world as such but
as soon as he becomes naked, he hides.
Well why?
Well that doesn’t need to be answered.
All you have to do is think about it.
Why would you hide if you know you’re naked?
Well, it’s simple.
You hide because you think you can get hurt.
You think that whatever you are is so vulnerable
that if it shows itself to the transcendent
to others, to the natural road that something
terrible will happen and then you think well
that’s a pretty logical pre-supposition
right?
Look at us.
So God comes cruising around the garden after
Adam and Eve eat the apple in the cool of
the day, and Adam and Eve hide themselves
among the trees of the garden.
And God says, hey Adam hey, where are you?
And Adam says, “I heard your voice and I
was afraid because I was naked and I hid myself”.
And that story has bottomless depth because
it means something like this.
At the beginning of Genesis, there’s this
notion that there is a transcendent relationship
between the individual and God, right?
The identity of logos and the individual right?
A notion by the way that our entire idea of
intrinsic human right is predicated on as
we’ve been at some pains to demonstrate.
A relationship between the limited and the
limitless eradicated by the dawn of self-consciousness.
Well what does that mean?
Well, let’s say you have a destiny just
for the sake of argument.
Right?
Because you are a being with a tremendous
history and an unbelievable potential.
So let’s say you have a destiny, just for
the sake of argument.
What would cause you to hide from that destiny?
Well, obviously your own reflection’s on
your mortal vulnerability, right?
How could I be characterized by any transcendent
power whatsoever when I’m susceptible to
social alienation, right?
When I have this body which is capable of
terrifying degeneration that will eventually
decay into old age and that is bounded by
death.
How could I be good for anything which is
precisely what this little story says.
And so God figures out that Adam and Eve at
the fruit and that’s pretty decisive move
because once you wake up, sorry, you’re
awake.
And he says, and this is not an injunction
by the way.
This is the description.
All right, you’ve done it now.
“And to the woman he says, I will greatly
multiply thy sorrow and thy conception.
In sorry shalt thou bring forth children."
Why?
Well, we have a big cortex, right?
Really big.
It grew fast and what that meant is that there
was an evolutionary arms race between skull
size, date of birth, and pelvic diameter girth.
The wider the pelvis, the less effectively
you can walk.
The larger the skull, the bigger the brain.
The younger the baby, the more dependent and
vulnerable.
So what do we have in the case of human beings?
The female human pelvis has already stretched
to the limits of its structural capacity.
So the hole in its center is as big as it
can get without compromising the structural
integrity of the pelvis while still allowing
women to walk and run.
So how have babies adapted to that?
Well that’s simple.
A mammal of our size should have a gestation
period of two years.
We have a gestation period of nine months.
Why?
You gotta get the damned baby out before its
head gets too big.
What does that mean?
Well, means it’s vulnerable, right?
Nothing more vulnerable than a baby human
being except maybe a baby kangaroo, right?
But it’s got a pouch to hide in at least.
So we’re born vulnerable, right?
Characteristic of the birth of the hero.
Who suffers in childbirth?
Women.
Why?
Baby skulls just a little bit too big.
Has to be crunched and compacted during birth,
right?
The skull bones aren’t joined together so
that the baby’s head can be squashed and
visibly deformed during the process of birth.
Prior to the twentieth century, what was the
death rate among women giving birth?
One in three?
One in five?
Terrible.
Why?
That’s the price you pay for self consciousness.
"And thy desire shall be to thy husband and
he shall rule over thee."
This is not an injunction.
This is a description.
The additional burden that dependent offspring
place on women, place them at a disadvantage.
What’s the consequence of that from a historical
perspective?
Well, any feminist can answer that question
right.
"And unto Adam, he said, because you listen
to your wife, and have eaten the tree, of
which I commanded thee saying don’t eat
that, cursed is the ground for thy sake.
In sorrow shall thou eat of it for all the
days of thy life."
Fair enough, right?
Once you’re self-conscious you work.
Why?
Well animals don’t work.
Why do people work?
Well, because we know, right?
We know that if it isn’t going to happen
today, it’s going to happen tomorrow.
And if it isn’t going to happen tomorrow,
well it’s going to happen next week or the
week after or the month after the year after.
And we bloody well better prepare.
So that’s what we do, constantly.
Prepare and prepare and prepare.
So we’re not bounded and motivated by what’s
happening from second to second.
Like the animal is in its still paradisal
state.
We’re constantly tormented by an endless
string of what if questions because when we
look at the unknown, we can see the possibility
for everything including our own punishment,
our own torment, our own demise and so we’re
motivated like no other animal to work.
And so we work.
But that is another aspect that alienates
from paradisal being.
"Thorn and thistles shall it bring forth for
thee and now shall eat the herb of the field,
in the sweat of thy face shalt thou eat bread
till thou return unto the ground, for dust
thou art and unto dust shalt thou return.
Right.
Therefore the Lord God sent Him forth from
the Garden of Eden to till the ground from
whence he was taken.
So he drove out the man and he placed to the
east of the Garden of Eden cherubims and a
flaming sword which turned every way to keep
the way of the Tree of Life."
Adam and Eve, right?
The Mother and Father of all humanity.
So you can give them a mythological slant
and you can say Adam is culture, say and Eve
is nature because they’re the archetypal
parents.
It’s a perfectly reasonable interpretation.
They have twin sons, Cain and Abel.
So let’s read first born creatures, first
born human creatures in the new self conscious
world.
So what are the first two individuals in the
new self-conscious world like and let’s
find out.
"And Adam knew Eve his wife and she conceived
and bearer of Cain and said, I have gotten
a man from the Lord.
And again she beared his brother Abel, the
younger brother.
And Abel was a keeper of sheep but Cain was
a tiller of the ground.
And in the process at time it came to pass
that Cain brought of the fruit of the ground
an offering unto the Lord."
Okay.
So, we’re going to remove this from its
- this story - from its entrapment in a particular
temporal domain and within a temporal culture.
We’re going to say something like this.
Well, if you work you make sacrifices right?
That’s what work’s all about.
And the reason you make sacrifices is because
you’re offering up to the unknown the fruits
of your labour in the hope that as a consequence
of your diligent effort, you’re going to
be favoured, right because otherwise why work?
The point of working is to transform the transcendent
into something benevolent.
So you work and you work and you work and
you say, is that sufficient?
And the answer you get from the transcendent
is the answer.
Now it’s certainly true that lots of people
work and it doesn’t go all that well, right?
They make sacrifices and they do what they
think they have to do and their life is one
string of catastrophes after another.
All right?
So we have this situation.
"In the process of time it came to pass that
Cain brought of the fruit of the ground an
offering unto the Lord.
And Abel, he also brought of the firstlings
of his flock, and of the fat thereof.
And the Lord had respect unto Abel and his
offering."
So what that means is that old Abel, working
away, may have things that are going great
for him right?
Fortune smiles on him.
He’s doing wonderfully.
He’s got everything he needs.
Well, okay and he’s scrounging away in the
ground and things aren’t going as well for
him at all, right?
Plagues, locusts, you-name-it.
Farm life isn’t going well.
So what happens?
Well, "Cain was very wrath that his countenance
fell."
Well, precisely right?
Because if you work diligently towards a certain
end and you don’t get there then your contenance
fell, falls, right?
You’re angry, frustrated, disappointed,
hurt, anxious, threatened, ashamed, guilty,
the whole panoply of negative emotions.
And that’s fair enough because of course
if you fail, that’s what’s going to be
the consequence
But then there’s this little twist on it?
Right?
This specifically human twist that, that’s
like that kind of moral of the whole story.
And so you find the Lord saying, “What,
you know, what’s up with you?
Why are you so unhappy?
If you just got your act together then you’d
be accepted.
If you really got your act together”
which is a statement something like this,
if you keep making sacrifices and the same
terrible thing keeps happening, there’s
always the possibility that you’re just
actually not doing it the right way.
And if you’d just get yourself straightened
up, tapped together, right?
And drop the preconceptions that you don’t
really need, and adjust your behaviour accordingly,
then fortune would smile on you.
And that’s exactly what the Lord says to
Cain, right?
You don’t walk around with such a crabby
look on your face.
If you did, well, you’ll be accepted and
if you don’t do well, sin lies at the door.
So what does that mean?
Well, this is a deep motif in ancient Hebrew
thinking.
If the world isn’t laying itself out in
a manner that you find acceptable, you’re
faced with a tough choice.
Either the world is a terrible place, bent
on your destruction or you’re doing something
wrong.
And it bloody well better be that you’re
doing something wrong because if the world
is a terrible place bent on your destruction,
you’ve got absolutely no hope.
“And Cain talked with Abel his brother and
it came to pass, when they were in the field
that Cain rose up against Abel his brother
and killed him.
“
So what does that mean?
Well, it’s pretty easy.
It’s simple.
It means this.
Well, say things aren’t that well for you?
And it’s really not because life’s unfair
and everything’s stacked against you.
It’s because you’re kind of a arrogant,
stubborn, quasi totalitarian, cowardly idiot.
And as a consequence of that, the world is
turning into something ressembling a wasteland
around you.
And you have this auction.
Change.
Or continue.
Oh, you have another option.
Man look around.
There’s all those people doing well.
The world’s a terrible place bent on my
destruction.
Couldn’t it be just the most interesting
thing if, as things are going to hell for
me, I could take a long, just for the ride,
some of those successful people who are successful
just for unfair reasons.
Anyways, right?
Instead of using all that negative emotion
as a cue that there’s something about me
that might need to be transformed, I can say
well why not just eradicate the target of
my resentment?
Right?
Not only because that sort of removes the
problem of comparison but more profoundly
– and I think sort of again – limitlessly,
profoundly.
Let’s say you make the decision that the
world’s a terrible place and it’s bent
on your destruction.
And then you think well what’s the logical
response to that?
And then you think something like this.
Goethe, Faust, Mephistopheles credo.
“The spirit I that endlessly denies and
rightly too for all that comes to birth is
fit for overthrow as nothing worth.
Wherefore the world were better sterilized
thus all that’s here is evil recognized
is gain to me and downfall, ruin and sin,
the very element I’d prosper in”
And Goethe draws our attention to this credo,
not once but twice in his writing of Faust
and has Mephistopheles say right, once again
"go on, to sheer nothing.
Passed With null made one.
/ What matters our creative endless toil /when
at a snatch oblivion ends the coil?/ It is
by gone, how shall this riddle run?
As good as if things never had begun yet circle
back existence to possess.
I’d rather have eternal emptiness.
"
And so then you think about Cain-like figures,
like Stalin.
And you think well what exactly was he motivated
by?
And on the one hand you think well, he was
trying to extend his cultural – dominion,
plagued by his own self-conscious nuroticism
he wanted to extend the borders of his totalitarian
certainty to every corner just to not be plagued
by the unknown.
and you think fair enough, we're all pretty
nervous and a little stability is a pretty
good thing.
Why?
Because they make a fundamental judgment,
which is the judgement of Mephistopheles.
Look: life is terrible.
terrible.
we're self conscious, we get sick, we go insane,
we're going to die, children, innocent children
suffer everywhere.
how in the world is it right to let such a
state continue?
maybe it will be better, all things considered
to just bring the whole thing to an end.
and then you think again with Eliade that
the reason human societies fall apart is two
fold, one is that things go from bad to worse
in their own accord right?
thermodynamic reality.
pure entropy.
structured entities decay.
but then there's a twist, structured entities
constructed by humans are sped in their process
of decay by the participants of the individuals
within that society who have essentnially
decided that the game is not worth the price
and that under such conditions the only reasonable
thing for a self conscious - painfully self
conscious - individual to do is to work as
hard as he or she possibly can to take the
maximum amount of revenge on the conditions
of existence and to ensure that the entire
game folds up and that consciousness disapears
and that being is eradicated.